[Music]
so today we're going to be talking about
democratizing AI for industrial
applications and also democratizing AI
in general so I modern Subramanian I
lead data science and analytics for big
huge G company I just wanted to start
off with some challenges and potential
opportunities that the oil and gas
industry presents and this is although
that slide is titled as an oil and gas
industry specific slide this is pretty
common for most of the traditional
industries that are out there today
right think about the left-hand side of
the equation where you have assets
systems very large scale critical
infrastructure that has been
commissioned over the last 30 to 50
years they're all aging they're in
different stages of aging different
stages of performance different stages
of reliability they all need to be
somehow upgraded and kept live at 90
percent or above reliability and
availability but to make things more
complex or rather interesting a lot of
the workforce that has kept these
systems up and running life and
understand these systems well slated to
the tile in the next five to ten years
so even if there are enough engineers
who will get trained and on-boarded into
these industries it's very very hard for
them to come up to speed and fill the
gap that these experienced engineers and
scientists and developers would leave
behind right so there has to be
something that bridges the gap between
the two and the cost of any of these
systems going down actually the
astronomical even today it's scary to
think about what will be the cost 10 or
12 15 years down the line the number
down there that is six point six billion
dollars in unplanned downtime cost that
is just for downstream in North America
so if you look at the unplanned downtime
costs across the world from upstream
that is where you extract oil midstream
where you transport oil and downstream
where you process it and then send it
off to gasoline or any of the other
petroleum products that numbers is in
hundreds of millions if not trillions
right now that's the challenge part of
the story the opportunity side is on the
right side now oil and gas industry has
enjoyed very high oil prices for a while
and also have enjoyed need or growth of
need across the board until about 2012
2013 where the oil price went from 130
barrel $30 a barrel to less than $40 a
barrel overnight and what that cost was
a sudden realization that the industry
was slightly lacking behind compared to
the aviation industry or the power
industry any of the traditional
industries and the need for sudden
digitalization the need for going after
something that they've not done came
about very very suddenly in the industry
and the oil prices have stabilized have
gone back down and up again but what is
what it is resulted in is the top right
figure that you see that where most of
the industrial companies that want to
invest in AI in any kinds of modern
technologies 75% of the fraction of
money that's going to be invested in AI
or invested in something analytics is
going to come from the oil and gas
market that's partly driven by the need
and partly driven by the fact that it
was lagging behind for some time now
they're catching up quite a bit right
now flip the equation a little bit and I
didn't grow up in the oil and gas
industry I actually grew up in the
aviation and power industry before
coming on to looking at problems that
require analytics in oil and gas the
first thing that surprised me was the
scale and quantity of data in oil and
gas so compare the volumes of data here
on the slide here to what you would see
in aviation of power so if you take off
from New York land in London
typically the aircraft was a car engine
generates about a terabyte of data out
of that terabyte of data you store maybe
a hundred megabytes because very
expensive the store very expensive to
transmit and traditionally it's not
something that the airline industry has
stored compare that to the oil and gas
industry where an offshore oil rig for
offshore oil platform generates anywhere
from 20,000 to 30,000 sensors generating
data every two to three seconds
stored in perpetuity since the day
platform was commissioned so 20 30 years
that's the data scientists bonanza and
if you can actually get to that data
correctly and do something about it
that's fantastic and that's the only
where the opportunity lies now I also
want to pinpoint one thing where
analytics means a lot of different
things to a lot of different people
right what it means to us from big huge
E&G in broad is the combination of three
very important things analytics is not
necessarily anything new if you look at
engineering if you look at any kinds of
systems where a large scale domain
knowledge that is required a combination
of domain and traditional software has
been around for decades that's what
produces traditional solutions that's
what runs the world today the new kid on
the block is what today is known as the
cool parts of data science that think of
your most favorite algorithm most common
buzzword out there
throw it in there that's data science
combined with a slightly different way
of writing software modern software on
the cloud automatically scalable
horizontally and vertically scalable now
that has also been proven to do some
things that are not possible from the
traditional solutions now if any of us
were told 10 years ago that a system
would automatically tell you when to
leave this stage today go home start at
4:30 so that you can actually get home
on time navigating all the traffic
making sure that you're actually on time
to take your daughter to a dance class
because your calendar knew that your
daughter has a dance class that your
phone knows that you are here and it
knows to navigate between those two
locations we all would have probably
laughed but that's solved today or think
of a case where a shop would send you
something before you even express the
intent that you like that thing that's
also solved like Amazon sends you stuff
today that you never once liked anywhere
little creepy but it's done and that's
the needle in a haystack kind of problem
very very hard problems to solve but
thanks to the googles and Amazon's in
the Facebook's and Apple's of the world
they have shown
the way to solve those things now
translate that to the industrial domain
most of the time that twenty thousand
sensors transmitting two to three second
data every every day for the last thirty
years they just tell us that the systems
are fine because the systems are
designed to be fine for a very long
period of time so if you go looking for
something meaningful in that data you
most of the time find nothing like all
the data means nothing to most of the
time the one time when the system fails
the one time that something actually
goes wrong you don't have any data about
that thing right and that's really what
is the problem that we're trying to find
where we're trying to find a needle in
an ocean of data not even a needle in a
haystack problem and most of the time we
don't even know what the needle looks
like right then that's the problems
we're trying to solve
I'll give you some examples of that but
before I go into that one I know I
introduced myself as the head of data
science but this is a tenet that we
believe very deeply in Earth's inner
things and this is something attributed
to George box he said it a long time ago
all models are wrong but some are useful
boxtop they're actually we go a little
further than that all models are wrong
some are useful for a short period of
time right and if you believe that very
deeply then you design your systems very
very differently you design your teams
differently you think about problems and
solutions differently so we don't
necessarily go into a problem saying hey
via the school data science team use
domain experts or subject matter experts
we've been designing the system and
running it reliably for last thirty
years don't know what we know so we'll
come solve that problem for you we
actually rarely do that sometimes we do
that and get paid for it but most of the
time it's this tenet that drives us and
I'll give you the reasons why and if you
think about this carefully any model
that we build even the most
sophisticated deep learning model that
you can build on thousands of hours of
GPU or TPU compute this tenet still
holds true so you have to have systems
that constantly update themselves
constantly go in and make sure that
they're monitoring your models so you
need models that monitor your models and
then you need a more more lucid
monitoring people who build the models
right so so that is where
our concept of digital twin was born and
most of the concept on the slide was
born out of pure necessity right so we
didn't really sit in an ivory tower to
think about this and said this is a
fantastic way to solve problems
we were actually posed with problems
where things like okay there's one
failure in the field there's one jet
engine that failed can you actually tell
from that one failure do you have to
take down an entire fleet of engines
down which causes a massive outage in
the entire transportation network in the
world or not safety issues where an
offshore oil platform just sent off an
alert do you shut down the platform
which cost you about fifty thousand
fifty million dollars a day if you shut
it down if you don't shut it down it's
going to cause an environmental disaster
that's going to go costing about a
trillion dollars over a period of five
to ten years those are the kinds of
answers you're trying to answer and most
of the time we don't have data to go
about solving the problem so the concept
of digital twin where the model is a
combination of the main we most often
just start with domain build around
traditional machine learning problems
that gives us the ability to solve known
problems very well so if I tell you
there's a crack the crack is propagating
because of a thermal load I can give you
very very very precise models that tell
you how the crack is going to propagate
under that load that's the known knowns
now if I go one level above and say I
don't necessarily know the temperatures
that are affecting this particular part
I can measure it to within plus or minus
ten degrees or 20 degrees that's a known
unknown so that unknown but the known
unknown of temperature I can propagate
through and tell you well this part is
going to fail within the next ten days
with a 90 percent probability right
that's where probabilistic inference
comes in the real advantage of using
deep learning for us is where I can't
necessarily post the problem in known
knowns or known unknowns cases where I
know that something is going to go wrong
but I don't necessarily know what to go
catch so I'll go back to the twenty
thousand sense an example we have twenty
thousand sensors emitting data every two
seconds I have written rules heuristics
watched all kinds of critical things
already I can catch maybe ninety percent
of the things that are going to go
what about the last 10% I don't know
what rules to write
I don't even know what to watch and how
often do I need to watch it for that's
really where deep learning systems come
into play that's how he actually got
into deep learning and then we as we
learned more and started deploying the
systems for we realized that it can also
tell us when to go update our models can
also tell us when to go watch what
models so I'll give you some examples of
that but before I go there I wanted to
give you an example of what we think
about as scale or systems of systems so
we most of the time look at systems that
are very very large so that offshore oil
platform has roughly about 30 different
large-scale systems in that each system
has anywhere from 10 to 15 large
subsystems each subsystem has 5,200
assets okay an asset would be something
like a gas turbine okay for those of you
are not seeing a gas turbine some of the
gas turbines fill rooms that are twice
this size so very very large scale
things that are considered a small asset
and they won't even be described in this
particular plot on the right side and
most of the time the answer or the
problem we're trying to solve is okay I
have data from all of these different
assets all of these different sensors
coming in what is going wrong I already
know to catch 90% of the things that are
going wrong
catch the 10% of the things that I
cannot catch high meaning the operator
of the actual platform right so what we
do is we actually convert the physical
system into an information network so we
know already how assets are connected
how subsystems are connected how systems
are connected the connectivity is what
is shown on the right hand side so each
a node there is actually an asset that
is connecting to each other maybe a pump
is connected to a fuel system a fuel
system is connected to a gas turbine the
gas turbine would be connected to a
compressor a whole lot of different
things like that physical connectivity
is shown on the right side but the
colors actually come from the data so
what we do is we take operational data
and try to understand purely from
operational data
is there anything connected with each
other without knowing how they're
connected in the physical space that's
the one on the left side now you
superimpose that on to the right-hand
side you see some interesting things you
start seeing things where
most of the systems seem to be connected
only with the assets inside that system
so if you look at the blue dots they're
only in the top left and maybe things
that are physically connected but there
are some green dots on the top right and
on the bottom left there is no physical
connection there is no direct physical
connection there's not even a second or
third order direct connection right but
your operational ADA is telling you that
there's something correlated so this
could be one of two things it's the
traditional or the classical problem of
correlation is not causation right well
this could very well be hey are you
trying to tell me that the S&P 500 index
is correlated to milk prices in
Bangladesh right you can definitely come
up with a data set that tells you that
now the proof of this exercise is can
you predict failures that you cannot
predict before and reliably and that is
here so we take this taking this
approach where we combine the physical
network with the operational history
connected it together built models very
large scale models will tell you about
what these models are and predicted what
was not known to us before so this is a
real example where a customer gave us
operational data for two years worth of
operations of one subsystem
sorry one system and then one system had
about 13 subsystems roughly 4000 sensors
that's what they call a proof of concept
about five terabytes of data right
we built our models all of these models
were a combination of auto-encoders
probabilistically enabled and a system
of system network models so all of them
combined together to predict a third
year's worth of data trying to figure
out if the model can predict things that
it hasn't seen before right and the
proof is we could successfully detect
all unplanned downtime events the events
that we hadn't seen we didn't know how
many events we just predicted 16 out of
16 events now I could have done that
very easily by just saying let me call
everything as an event I could have
caused 1600 failures and that would have
included the 16 failures that was
actually real so to make sure that a
model was not over 200 just junk or just
flipping a coin we also made sure that
we can compare it with the current
scenario of how do you catch false so we
were able to get all unplanned
time events by reducing false-positives
and false-negatives simultaneously right
and this one we can do repeatably and to
do this repeatedly we actually have to
go through many different pipelines
right so if you think about this you got
data you validate the data you walk
through say an architect's a space you
give it to a data scientist they say
okay I know for this particular problem
I can get to a model that looks good
maybe I'll use a particular type of auto
encoder maybe I use a particular type of
LST M I'll get a model and the data
scientist time is very valuable usually
you build maybe one or two maybe three
or four iterations and you stop that's a
typical workflow from the left to right
in our case because we didn't have the
luxury to say okay I have a prediction
you will give me the results of a blind
validation test and I can go back and
update my models I still have to go
build models without knowing what my
validation data set is or the true test
data set is so we actually have to go
build and explore the entire
architecture space and come up with
models that we know are not just a model
but a very very good model to begin with
so the way we do it is we actually start
with initial samples that you see here
those are the red crosses where we say
we let me go explore the design space
and use that to build a Bayesian meta
model so this is a meta model that tells
you okay if I change the number of
layers if I change the activation
functions do a use regularization or not
that is if you decide that you're going
to use some kind of a deep neural
network or you can also go in and say
let me go build a Gaussian crosses model
or I'll just go build a simple linear
regression model all of those are
different search spaces that we are
searching across use it to build a meta
model and then use a genetic algorithm
to go optimize all of those different
variables simultaneously so it's a
massive optimization exercise that goes
from the red dot through all the gray
dots to get you to those green Pareto
optimal points now typically you may be
used to seeing optimization problems as
going up and north has to be good here
the two objectives are lost functions so
you want it to be as small as possible
so you're ready using loss in different
dimensions to get it is very very small
values right you get to an objective to
get
here we had to use stencil flow at its
edge we had to go back and use cue flow
at its edge and I'll show you how we did
that and combine all of this with
tensorflow probability as well of course
all of these running on NVDA nzc
containers as well the nice thing is to
get to a model we could go explore more
than a quarter million architectures
very rapidly for one model right so
we're just going in building one model
here and the improvement in training
from just a random search is at least 10
times and ten times is what we can
achieve consistently so you gave us give
it to the best data scientists we have
on team they go and find out saying okay
this model will work for this particular
use case I know I've built it a hundred
times let me go build it compare to that
you still come up with architectures
that are significantly better now if you
flip the question and ask us do you
understand the architectures do you
understand why something is working the
answer is no many many times we actually
look at that and say why exactly is it
working I don't know and I don't really
know if I pick that particular
architecture but it works in this
particular use case right and this is
for one model so for the offshore oil
platform that I've been talking about
that platform has about 40 systems each
of those systems would have about eight
of these models and so the scale you're
talking about is significantly high and
to get this to run properly of course
costs a lot of GPU computer right and as
most of you probably know in this room
GPUs reasonably expensive and running
them at this scale can break the bank
right now the general question we face
is are you guys crazy do you really
really want to go run this many models
at scale this is the plot we actually
use with our CFOs as well so that's the
anomaly detection model on the left side
that's actually at scale from the
previous slide the model that Facebook
open sourced just last month on open go
my DLF model that model ran on 2,000
GPUs for two weeks
so compared to the scale of operations
that we're talking about where a model
saying something wrong can give you an
outcome that will get the business to
lose tens of millions if not
so millions actually is very very
limited the reason why there's a sticker
shock in these kinds of cases is we are
not used to building these kinds of
models up to this point in time for
these kinds of operational histories we
don't really build these models like
that today if you ask us how an offshore
oil platform is managed it's probably
managed with a spreadsheet but what's
lost in that spreadsheet calculation is
all of the effort that goes in in
getting a simple answer to the operator
imagine what the operator can do with a
model which will tell you 50 days or
hundred days before that something is
going to happen and you can change your
operations the financial impact of that
is significant right now to do all of
these things at scale we don't need to
orchestrate things very very differently
so for us everything runs inside
containers containers is a first-class
citizen and it's not just that we get to
build these cool new models we also have
to live in the world of models that have
existed for the last thirty years which
are running reliably most of the times
we can't necessarily go recode them or
change them and most of the time we
don't need to change them right so the
workflow that's shown here where you
start with a Python model it goes into
some proprietary model say for an
example is Isis there's a Fortran model
that feeds something into that pipeline
that goes into something else it's
Python that might actually run a robust
optimize it and go is actually fairly
common for us we don't necessarily use
Fortran for that much but for 2077 is
something we have quite a lot of know
and that's not just for oil and gas any
industry as well so you need to be able
to run all of these things
simultaneously at scale orchestrate it
and get an answer back to the user right
now the example I showed before where
you actually start with some few red
crosses that's the initial points on the
top there's an actual queue for pipeline
that's implemented to run both on-prem
as well as on a cloud will show you
running this on GCP today that's the
initial model running after all of those
models are run cube FLOTUS I said okay
let me go build this Bayesian model and
then spawn off yet another set of models
after i optimize that's the second
iteration you keep going to multiple
iterations finally you get to an optimal
architecture right now the data
scientist who's building these models
does not know much about Bayesian models
or even optimization the optimization
expert who's who knows and understands
stochastic optimization does not know
what models are actually being optimized
the software architect who makes sure
that all of these things run at scale
GPUs when you require GPUs actually are
available and all of these things
actually are available when a data
scientist kicks off a run that's not
necessarily understand any of this you
need to be able to orchestrate all of
these things together to run at scale
right now to even get there we had to
make sure that okay you can go ask for
100 GPUs or a thousand GPUs or a hundred
thousand GPUs from GCP they may give it
to you and it's a lot of money on your
site to go get those hardware actually
available to you but do you actually
have the software to go load them up at
scale so this is a load balancer that we
wrote and they this is a result of test
run where we have two systems competing
with each other every time the load
balancer sees that all of these GPUs or
all the resources are consumed it'll add
a node with the GPU so that's what's
happening on the top left so each time
it hits something you add a node right
the actual load or utilization per GPUs
on the bottom left immediately after a
GPU node is added the total utilization
goes down right so there is something
else that's watching that says okay the
total utilization has gone down I
actually have more resources I can
reload them back up so there is a
constant tug-of-war going on between
these two systems
well the load drops and it goes back up
as soon it goes back up I'm at the GPU
node is added until of course you hit a
point where you can't spin anymore so
that's what happens when you hit to ten
nodes with two GPUs each so getting up
to this level of scaling where you had a
GPU node you get it instantly your
billing starts instantly but most of the
time you can't use it instantly so you
to be careful about that right and after
you're done you need to be able to shut
it down instantly because billing
continues to go right so this one
running the same queue flow experiment
that we showed before is what is shown
here so we ran the first experiment the
load spikes on the top left then the
basin optimization runs so the load
drops
then the second load goes back up an
interesting thing that's happening on
the bottom right you can see is each of
the times it hits max load it actually
adds more notes and once all of the
initial runs are done it spins it back
down way below where it started right
and this has to happen consistently
across the board because many times we
have 10 20 30 data scientists running
these pipelines and we can't necessarily
have a Saudis on standby to keep
increasing GPUs or even watching do you
have the ability to run GPUs or not I'm
picking on GPUs a bit here because
that's reasonably expensive but if you
use TP use it's the same thing even not
even any compute if you're using
high-performance storage for example
that can also break the bank
so it'll be very careful about loading
at these kinds of scales right and this
is another example of as showing that we
can actually run through all of these
architecture steps and keep the GP
utilization at or above 80% that alone
is not a simple problem to crack right
so when you're thinking about scale also
think about the fact that if you acquire
hardware or acquire virtual hardware you
also need software that can scale with
the virtual ER or actual real hardware
now how did we get here
the the title of the talk is
democratizing AI and I promise I will
get back to that doing all of these
things is not necessarily unique for oil
and gas
almost all industries out there are
solving one hard problem or the other
and to get to anything at scale you need
more than one or two types of
disciplines right and we got here by
blood and sweat and very hard work by a
lot of people in very disparate and
different communities right so we had
data scientists but lumping all data
scientists into one large bucket is also
not being that fair to them right there
are traditional machine learning
researchers there are probabilistic
researchers and also a lot of deep
learning researchers working together to
get us to where we are today domain
experts are the folks who told us what
to go solve for so we didn't really go
to them and say give us your easy
problems we'll just make them faster we
actually told them give us the problems
that you can't solve or have not been
able to solve give us your heart
problems and help us
and them to the point where we can at
least tell you whether we can solve them
or not and we had we walked into
problems where we had a certainty of
maybe fifty percent to think that we can
solve it and many cases it is necessary
because those are the problems that
could justify the cost of using a system
like this right and software again is
not all created equal right so these
that we put these specific words here
because thinking about software and
silos also causes a lot of problems most
of our software engineers were
full-stack they also were very
experienced in distributed systems and I
will talk to you about that why and
thinking about cloud native is something
we had to learn along the way right we
started with systems that were
completely on-prem and then moved to the
cloud thinking okay we can more or less
modify it a little bit to get to the
cloud only when we started hitting
scales of the problems that we had to
solve we realized that we have to go
rewrite a lot of different things so if
you want things to run at scale be
willing to rewrite 30 40 sometimes 50
percent of your systems okay so what is
democratizing AI mean because I thought
about this a little bit for this talk
and I've been thinking about this for a
while it means different things to
different people now if you are a data
science researcher a data scientist or a
practitioner who's been doing this for
many years when you hear the word
democratizing AI you probably think okay
I know how to build my models I have my
tools I'm going to continue doing that
I'm very very good about using and
tooling myself but I don't necessarily
know how to make my models available for
hundreds if not thousands of people
repeatably so production izing a model
is probably what people think of when
you're a data science researcher an
expert and by the way i looked up the
word productionize is a word apparently
in if you're a domain expert or a
business user or somebody who hears a
lot about AI who's heard about all the
buzz maybe write something about
yourself and find that most of the
tooling is hard to use most of the
jargon is very hard to understand and
many times you can't connect a outcome
that looks nice to the outcome that you
care about then you want to be able to
build these models fast and
roxanna is very very fast right now if
you're a software developer if you're an
applications developer you may not
necessarily care about the specific
nuance of an algorithm or a specific
nuance of how the model has been reduced
to a size that can be scaled and say
served well somebody already did that
work you care more about how do I
consume it for the particular use case
you have in mind now any of the tool
sets out there any of the tooling out
there people building tools for
democratizing AI have to cater to all of
these three different very different say
workloads right and we've been doing
this for a while and mostly because of
necessity for ourselves because we had a
small team which has to scale to very
large problems as well as very very
large scale systems so we made some very
careful choices right so being container
first was by necessity and I'll give you
some metrics on what going to containers
it to us so we did come up with a
philosophy called depend on darker
that's the logo for it obviously we like
doing things hence do depend on docker
and everything we run is containerized
except for raw storage
everything is containerized right and we
also make sure that that means we have
to orchestrate at scale as well so we'll
show you a demo of a model and a set of
models running at scale today but before
I get to the demos just what did it do
to us
so like rewind five years ago when we
were trying to build what we called at
that point in time a digital twin
platform for GE we would build a
technique we would build a model that
would be in the research phase getting
that model into production meant that we
had to stick to very very strong say
quarterly releases and every single
quarterly release would go up to the
midnight before the release and
something that was working just fine the
day before would break and most of the
time it was some dependency or rather
than the mortal cycle and the number of
times we heard hey this is working just
fine on my laptop or is working just
fine on my system it's something wrong
with your production system just throw
as nuts to be honest we moved to
containers and five years ago moving the
containers was not that part
we had to still face comments like Oh
nobody would ever let you Brown
containers in our system to today where
everybody learns everything in
containers it moved the production
deployment of a model that has already
been validated taking 6 months to
roughly an hour so the model has already
been validated by somebody it's a data
scientist a subject matter expert they
agree that model going from being in
their systems to a production system is
roughly in our for us today right of
course it doesn't always happen in one
hour every time but if the data
scientist was say disciplined enough to
use our tooling from day one and
actually have everything running in
containers those containers transmitting
into our production systems is under an
hour
so that's really what going to
containers and sticking with discipline
got us right now the demo use case I
will show you two different types of
flavors the first one is a simple case
where I'm just going to take a data set
run it through some algorithms that'll
detect what is in this data set
and tell you what possible models we can
build on a UI actually it will build
several different kinds of models to get
you to a best model but the same demo
will also run and show you that this can
scale across thousands of models built
live on stage and there was a promise in
the abstract as well and we hopefully if
the demo gods agree today we will show
the demo working today to get that to
work we obviously need high speed
storage but a lot of the core services
had to scale as well and we had to break
it down to a point where we can control
things at a very fine grain level and if
you see at the top we have both gke
clusters and self-managed clusters and
in this particular case we did that
because we were experimenting with
things but it actually came back to
service because the recent update from
1.14 introduced a non backward
compatible change and that broke our
self-managed clusters for the GK
clusters are up so actually preparing
for this talk we were fine actually
going through preparing as we were
upgrading our self-managed clusters as
well so I'll walk you through how to do
that but
this is the cluster we will be showing
you hopefully live running we have a
master node and what is expanded on the
right hand side is just the master node
the lines are not necessarily correct so
we have 100 nodes per cluster that's the
GK master cluster on the top are five
workload clusters on the bottom are five
self managed clusters so I'm going to
kick off some model run times and that
will actually load all of these
different cases as well so before I go
run spin up all of those clusters I just
wanted to show you a demo of what a
subject matter expert would do if we
didn't know anything about what is in
the data set so this is our AI system
called a factory where I just come in
and drag and drop a data set okay the
data set is simple tabular data as you
can see it just has one header with in
this particular case I think five
variables and about hundred rows of data
and this is the data set that we just
created to tell you what is how do you
predict a wear and tear of a of a wheel
depending on how fast you're
accelerating in the car what surface
you're driving on and things like that
so what happened here it's saying okay
it knows that it's a CSV file it wants
to see if we can build guided built now
going from that first page to here what
happened was it understood what is in
the file and this is granted a small
file but if you had a large file with
millions of rows it'll do the same thing
it understood what are the variables in
the file that are numeric and also went
in and said okay given that these are
the variables you have these are the
potential variables that you can use as
outputs in your system and that means
that for each of those outputs it will
go in and use the rest of the variables
as inputs and try and build your best
model and it not only did that it went
back and said okay here are all the
different techniques in the system
they're already pre-loaded that can be
used with this data set now remember if
you're if you're a subject-matter expert
you don't necessarily know what all of
these techniques mean you don't
necessarily need to care you just got
here the system is suggesting something
let it continue to go on up to a point
where it built some models and then you
can evaluate if the model is useful or
not that's we are going with it now
you don't necessarily agree with the all
the variables that it shows for example
if I don't want to build a model for
friction but I want to build the model
for acceleration I could do that as well
and then I go in and say okay build all
24 models now a couple of things need to
happen for this to work right where it
needs to take this data set split that
into testing and training connected to
all of these different techniques select
all the defaults and then come out with
the best models now in the time frame
that I just said that it went in built
all those models life came back and said
it's telling us what are the best models
for each kind of output that the system
told us now some of these output outputs
may not necessarily make sense for
example I don't necessarily want to
build a model for weight but I want a
model for where I want to model for
acceleration for example and it also
went in and said out of the six
techniques it went and evaluated for
each of the output it's telling you
what's the best model based on a
particular root mean square error like
it's a simple example I can annotate
scale here on the UI now what if instead
of having six variables you actually had
10,000 variables or instead of building
24 models you want to build 10,000
models or 100,000 models so we have a
CLI for that as well so let me switch to
that and to just walk you through this
one I have 10 cube contexts running on
the left-hand side and each one so the
first left-hand side ones are gke
clusters so the GK 1 2 all the way to 5
on the right hand side are our
self-managed kubernetes clusters so
that's the tower you saw so the
left-hand side is GK right hand side is
self-managed and I'm going to just run a
simple watch command so I'm going to
just watch the pods and most of it is
telling you that no resources are found
that means nothing is actually happening
there because I have not run anything
yet right now let me go in here and run
the case where I'm
actually spinning up the same thing
where we are simulating 10 different
users running a thousand models each
right so it's going to spin up 10,000
models simultaneously across all of
these different clusters so if I hit
this cluster and my fingers okay what
you're going to see is different colors
going through so each color is one
particular kubernetes cluster so it's
actually loading all of the kubernetes
cluster simultaneously and what you're
going to see is on the left hand side
each of the clusters actually starting
to to get loaded right and you can see
some of them started and it's processing
each of the nodes are going to process
about 1200 models now if I go back to
our system that's monitoring all this so
what you're seeing are all of the ten
clusters along with the management
cluster okay and what you're seeing is
the blue dots are as a management
cluster the ten kubernetes clusters are
around them and the white dots that are
popping up in are the models that are
being built live as I started building
it okay and the total number of services
that are running to make this possible
is well over a thousand services and the
jobs you can see the job count is
actually going up life so it looks like
the demo gods are five smiling on us now
we did build another case where a
hundred thousand models were running
live and I wanted to show that system as
well I'll come back and show you these
numbers and this is a case where all
100,000 models ran and completed and I
can go back to to this case reduce the
speed a little bit little bit so this is
what
a system that builds 100,000 models look
like and this was run life thank you you
can see the models are still being built
it's still being submitted and the
interesting piece here is to get to this
level of scale you can see all of them
have been submitted kubernetes is still
responding and actually kicking off the
jobs so the load balancing here not only
had to watch what is it load on the
system it also had to be optimized to
the level where it's watching which of
these clusters or which of these
kubernetes clusters are having a delay
in the responding back so sometimes the
kubernetes api takes two seconds to give
us a response back so in cases like that
we won't necessarily go load up that
particular cluster we'll move the load
to somewhere else so it's not just that
it's watching what is the what is
happening inside those clusters it's
also watching kubernetes right now you
built all these models you want to know
what is the best model so you can run a
query across all of these models that
just got built it'll come back and tell
you that it's not just one answer right
so you need to know whether it's a best
model based on root mean square error
that was what we showed on the UI but
you can also say that is the best model
based on max percentage error or average
percentage error or any of the different
percentages errors that you care about
as a data scientist or as a subject
matter expert as well right and all of
this so this is coming live from the
system that is actually running there
right and this you can see the jobs are
continuing to be submitted there you go
okay so we did show you real well world
use cases that require a lot of scale
and getting to scale requires you to
think slightly differently and also
think about scale from day one thinking
about scale at day 10 or day 100 causes
a lot more angst in thinking about it
they won right and we had to learn that
painfully on many of our applications as
well but what we showed you today was
using darker kuben arrays cube flow GCP
ng C containers in a way that is
significantly scalable and it's
definitely scalable but it takes quite a
bit of effort as well so I want to end
this with credits from the team that's
listed here and many many more
who works tirelessly for several years
to get us here so thanks a lot guys
thank you
[Music]